all right Ashley it's time for the big
surprise all right you guys can I have
everyone's attention please
you know the beautiful Miss Ashley is
the last of the banks to be celebrating
the grand tradition of turning 13.
and what better way to celebrate than
with a woman who knows everything about
being untraditional ladies and gentlemen
my friend the Poppin sweetie
[Applause]
Girl Hillary told me you're a big fan
but I'm a bigger fan of you and I just
want to say happy birthday
to you
happy birthday to you
happy birthday
dear Ashley
always Ashley make a wish
it already came true
oh come on I'll help you
[Music]
[Applause]